welcome to the across the spoiler ver
podcast baby we're back we're Back in
Black we're coming out everyone's loving
it everyone's celebrating that we're
finally back it's only been a week but
Greg it's been one of the longest weeks
of my life I took that holiday I came
back I've worked every single day since
then Saturday and Sunday when there's a
ComicCon on you don't get it off but
we've got some brilliant trailers to
talk about I'm very excited Greg how's
it going it's going well man um when we
were restarting this program I was on
Twitter wherever they're shooting
Deadpool 3 they need to move
locations like
immediately stuff is just leaking left
and right I don't understand what's
going on man Kevin FY he's sitting with
that sniper pointing at people like
Andrew Garfield and Patrick Stewart he
needs to turn it to whoever's taking
these photos because guy you're a menace
and I tell you why because Greg you
might remember a couple of weeks well
months ago now before this strike um
when the Deadpool footage leaked yeah we
we used it in our videos in a fair use
way and behind the scenes yeah pretty
much every YouTuber who us it got hit
with either a copyright strike or a
threat of a copyright strike and there
were some YouTubers who got contacted
directly by the photographer and they
got extorted out of money and he he was
basically saying like I'll drop the
copyright strike if you give me $1,000
it's like mate it's fair it's fair used
to talk about it it's out there
worldwide everyone's seen it you can't
just be like taking down videos saying
that you own footage from a set that you
snuck onto and took photos of but I
don't want to get into it I'm sure he's
a big fan of this he sent me a couple of
copyright
strikes sure oh God no I YouTube
actually protected me and Josh from den
of nerds and we we basically got a whole
email chain of things where we could see
all of his responses and every time that
YouTube rejected him and YouTube was
saying like look you haven't provided
evidence of how they're they're breaking
copyright on this image by talking about
it and he was like well I own the image
and it's mine to use I like come on mate
it's all over Twitter it's all over the
Internet it's being used in newspapers
I'm pretty sure a YouTuber just talking
about it so there's something funny
going on Greg but huge shout out to
YouTube for actually doing the right
thing with a copyright claim for once
because yeah I know one YouTuber who got
hit with two strikes and they just ended
up paying the guy off because they
didn't want any more of the hassle which
when it's a three it's a three strike
policy guys so yeah I mean he he
messaged me for advice and I was like
well I'm okay but if I was you in your
position I probably would do that
because uh yeah it's it's better off
just having no strikes on the channel
and and not worrying about it but we've
got some positive stuff to talk about um
so yeah lots of trailers at ccxp I seen
that Florence Pew got thrown something
out on stage the hell was that what was
what was going on there was it just like
someone being like participating and
accidentally hit Florence Pew I saw a
lot of people saying you missed Timothy
but I don't I don't think it was someone
participating in it and just throwing
stuff um I don't know if they were
trying to hit her on purpose or if it
was just a general shot at the the crowd
but yeah pretty it sucks I can't imagine
sitting in a crowd and throwing stuff at
a group of actors but she could have
could have lost her eye like that if
that over there could have lost could
have been really really bad situation
what is it with these people who are
standing off to the side throwing stuff
filming stuff and just then extorting
people for it Greg i'm bloody sick of it
but yeah lots of stuff to talk about so
I want to go onto the boys season 4
trailer first what were your thought on
it I was surprised by how it was more
serious than normal that like normally
when the boys comes out with their
trailers they kind of lean into the the
really fun side of things like the the I
remember season 3 had that Imagine
Dragon song that I've been addicted
toing in yeah we can't we can't see too
much of it but uh yeah when that that
that was a really really fun one which
led into like the violence and the
sexuality and Dick exploding yeah this
one really LED more into the uh the the
bleakness of the situation and with it
being election year coming up uh they
they they zeroed in on all those vibes
uh throughout this is gonna be very very
topical for the boys the boys has always
been a very topical show very political
commentary heavy and with it being
election year I can only imagine just
how much more they're goingon to throw
down and I I mean I think it looks great
I think it looks awesome I'm very
excited for it I'm very very excited for
it really Successful video
congratulations Paul thank you and I've
got some good news as well it's an
election year in the UK next year as
well so we well I can't wait to go
through it and see what it's going to be
so fun covering all this the boys during
a time when there's two elections going
on I can't wait because people are
really good at keeping their politics to
themselves and not getting angry at you
because you mentioned how something's
similar to something else but yeah I
actually messaged the boy's account um
on Twitter privately and I was like hey
mate this was like Wednesday I was like
hey mate are are you guys dropping the
trailer this weekend at ccxp and they
just said sorry mate don't know what any
of those words mean and I got a Friday
and they replied with hey mate found out
what those words mean the trailer's
coming tomorrow and I was like yeah
awesome so I was really happy um I love
the boys trailer yeah I completely agree
that imagins Dragon song Greg I just
want to quash the rumors before I get
canceled I'm not a big imagins dragon
fan yeah but I like that trailer so much
and I watched it so much that I just
know that song off the top of my head H
but yeah they are kind of going sort of
it's very you know how what's that
phrase that's going around the last
couple of years how often do you think
about the Roman Empire they're talking
about Caesar in it they've got Illusions
to like the fall of Rome yeah it looks
epic um but yeah I think I think it's
going to be good you know there's some
questions that people have about stuff
I'm actually dropping a video tomorrow
about what's going or today it's already
out today sorry and about what's
happening with black noir how he might
be back um yeah and there's lots of
things to talk about new soups in it
yeah
element is uh that has some massive
implications if you know how the boys
Comics go which we will not go into but
that there's some massive implications
with black and War being back yeah so
make sure you're tuned into the channel
because the videos already out s the
podcast go check that out and the next
trailer was Fallout which I actually
skipped because I was busy getting ready
for the other trailers that were coming
but I've actually watched it before just
before this um I'm not a big Fallout fan
I know people are like why haven't you
covered it I'm sorry mate I don't know
everything about everything and i' not
really played The Fallout games um I
think Mt is going to be covering it for
the channel he's a much bigger fan than
I am but I don't want to ring him up and
be like Mate MT get to work it's
Saturday I don't care what the hell
you're doing when either the Fallout
trailer done um but yeah from what I saw
you know it was as someone who only
knows like certain iconography from the
game series such as like the dogs the
ghouls of maybe uh the guys in the big
metal suits I've seen all that stuff
obviously pit pit boys as well um and it
it did kind of capture them really well
kind of um as someone who's not really
fully integrated with this world I
thought it it was good at holding my
hand through how things are going to be
um so yeah looks looks good it looks
awesome I'm a big fan I mean you were to
of the Westworld show that Jonathan
Nolan helmed and it's sad badly did not
get its final season that it
deserves really bumped me up and I
didn't know Jonathan I I knew literally
nothing about this and I I haven't
played any of the games I get a lot of
flack for that like you I might see an
image and go that looks familiar oh
that's from Fall oh yeah that's right
that's fall okay I didn't didn't realize
that but this looks like an the the
sensibilities of the trailer are
everything that speaks to me I I I did
love Westworld and seeing Nolan behind
it you get a lot of those West World
Vibes because it feels just like a giant
apocalyptic Western with kind of this
mob dark sense of humor and it's going
to be very violent at the same time uh
I'm really looking forward to it dude
and apparently for the Fallout for the
for fans of the game apparently this is
very much the tone and Sensibility that
that the game is whereas like with Last
of Us I remember when that trailer came
out
it was all the shots in it were this
looks exactly like the game this is a
onetoone adaptation of the game and I
don't think that's the case with this I
to my understanding that they are
telling their their own story if I could
be wrong correct me but I believe they
are telling their own story with while
there will be like familiar imagery and
whatnot but they are going down their
own original path with it that is still
connect to the games but unlike last of
us which was we're gonna do the game and
change some stuff that might upset some
people or some people might love it but
I'm excited for it a lot of good trailer
every trailer was good I don't think
anyone's going to fall out with you over
at Greg um but did you see the Halo
trailer because I didn't I I'm I've
always been a PlayStation and a Nintendo
guy myself and I just didn't see the
Halo trailer I know it's season two but
drop a comment below if you guys saw it
what you thought about it but that was
another big trailer along with richer
season 2 didn't watch the Richer season
2 trailer and it's purely because I've
got early access to the show and I'm
just thinking like well I just watch the
show I don't yeah and I'm not saying
that to brag Greg I'm just like oh I've
got a trailer to a show can already
watch um the next one I want to talk
about is furiosa which yeah it it's
weird because it's so green screened but
it it's almost kind of over stylized but
I I think when it's all like that it
kind of works to fit a sort of tone for
it um Chris Hemsworth I I was watching a
thing is that is that Chris himsworth
but they've done something to him they
give they give him a bit of a crooked
nose I've got a crooked nose guys come
on stop stealing you know that's
that's crooked no's appropriation that
making himself look uglier by making
himself look more like me H but yeah I
thought it looked like Cinema like one
of the tweets I saw was I'm sick of them
doing sequels and prequels to stuff but
I think when it's George Miller it's
it's kind of different because he
obviously I mean the guy's prettyy much
just made Mad Max movies for most of his
career yeah um so yeah when he makes
another Mad Max movie I don't it would
be like George Lucas making another Star
Wars thing you know what I mean it's not
necessarily like the guy's just milking
it it's like no he came up with this
franchise he just likes telling you
stories you know Jr talkin when he's
writing the s marilan or whatever it's
not milking it he just he's created that
world and he wants to write more of it
yeah
exactly I think it looks good I I don't
it at all I mean the CGI in it didn't
bother me as much as it bothered other
people it was something that did draw my
eye more than I expected it to I think
it's because like the last Mad Max movie
has CGI but it was so Innovative with
its use of designs like it whole
production design was so like batshit
insane and we had never seen anything
like it even though it was the fourth
entry in this franchise George Miller
had reinvented it and the the entire
aesthetic was just so
mindblowing that whenever now there's
CGI in the trailer uh you it does draw
your eye in but I'm like no the last
movie definitely had CGI and it'll
probably look better by the time the
film comes out and I don't even I don't
know too if like it probably had
something to do with the last movie was
a disaster for them to put together it
heard was just an entire troubling set
and even Charlie ston and Tom Hardy have
spoken publicly together in the room
about how they did not get along on set
just because of how high the tensions
were and how troubling everything was so
maybe they decided to use CGI a little
bit more just to make life a bit easier
on them because it's been a few years
Fury Road been quite a few years and and
now we're finally getting furiosa so
maybe they wanted to implement a little
bit more CGI to make life a little bit
easier on themselves is at the end of
the day I don't feel like it's going to
be I don't think it's going to be
comparable to Lord of the Rings in The
Hobbit where you're watching this
beautiful you know practical effects and
suddenly everything is CGI I feel like
maybe there's probably going to be just
a little bit more CGI than we might
expect and
this great that the other side I'm
looking forward to there is kind of even
I think it creates a stylized look for
it um and there is kind of that look
also on the actors themselves like Ana
Tyler Joy kind of had I think the way
they do the coloring and the contrast
and Lighting on them like Chris Emsworth
as well they have this sort of stylized
look to them where they almost appear
like .5% CGI themselves so I felt like
they kind of worked with the background
but obviously they've got time to work
on it it's not like Doctor Who this week
where they were walking down that
Thousand Mile Long Corridor and it was
like what the hell is this but part of
doctor Hugh's charm is of course
absolutely terrible CGI yeah but yeah it
was it wasn't at that level so yeah um
now speaking of things with great
production values Greg House of the
Dragon season two my again I think it's
going to be a banger um obviously you
know I I can't explain well I can't tell
you how many times I've went through the
D's chapters on the book um and yeah
just to see it brought to life and know
where it's going there's little shots
here and there like um blood and cheese
you know and some certain things that if
you know you know and I thought watching
this trailer it hasn't got a massive
reception online to be honest I'm
actually surprised at how little views
it has in comparison to the other things
but watching it as a House of dragon fan
yeah got really good trailer I think it
worked really well well I can speak to
it as someone who hasn't read the books
as a matter of fact for every episode
what was great about your breakdowns I
remembering this now is that you you
have a se you do your breakdown and then
you have a section that if you don't
want spoilers because you're going to go
into the book now I would I would have
to be one of those people who would
click off because I I do the reactions
and I don't want to know what's gonna
happen next so I have no idea hit the
thumbs up on the way out though I always
hit the thumbs up and I'll still give
you a good watch time because that
spoiler is at the end of the video
but the um the the trailer itself I like
the trailer a lot I can see though why
maybe it's not the Talk of the Town
because as some maybe like for someone
like yourself who knows the books and
really knows the source material you can
see the imagery and everything they're
flaunting on screen and go oh I see what
this is I see what this is I see what
this is whereas for myself it I think it
looks great and I love the tone of it
overall and it and it is very
melancholic and it feels like it's going
to go more epic same time it didn't
really quite show me anything that felt
completely new I don't want this to
sound like a slight against it because I
really did love the trailer I did I
loved it a lot uh but it I could I'm
trying to understand why maybe it didn't
become as big of a talk it's because I
feel like it doesn't ultimately show you
something that feels completely new just
yet I feel like that's what the next
trailer is going to be and they probably
want to preserve as much of their
storytelling points for the actual
season itself since people will tune in
even if it's a week even if it's a week
trailer people are going to tune in for
season two the show way too big and uh
well yeah I I was actually speaking to
Ryan bloody Ryan AR you know the lad I
think you've mentioned him before when
you said shut the up Ryan AR I
think you that was you who said that and
but yeah he messaged me when it released
and we were kind of both of us were like
it's difficult to do a breakdown on this
trailer because it's all sort of shots
out of context and the way I approached
my breakdown was I'm just going to talk
about what happens in the book in
chronological order and sometimes I'll
match it up with a shot on screen to
kind of show what's going on but I'm
basic basically just talking about what
happens in the book um and yeah I think
out of context I was saying to him I
it's so it is quite a difficult thing if
you're just going to go through this
shot by shot and try and say because
there's not really a narrative to it um
for
example no way home that first trailer
you know it had it had a story to the
trailer where it's like Peter Parker
it's like everyone's ruining my life I
can't believe how bad it is I'm going to
go to doctor strange and then you see
doctor strange doing the spell and then
the spell goes wrong and then you the
other characters from the spiderverse
start appearing and it has like a story
to the trailer itself whereas this was
kind of just like shots of characters
shots of characters people talking over
the top being like something is going to
happen and it's like next character like
I will make sure this thing happens and
you will regret it and the next shot's
like we will fight back so it's kind of
stuff like that so out of context yeah I
can see if you don't actually know what
these shots saw just like it just looks
like cool character shots yeah might
even be might from season one like some
of these shots yeah but yeah I mean I'm
excited for um again wow I'm for blank
on everyone rera that's her name right
rera
uh F CES Rea you know when a is the guy
with patch a aimon yeah yes yeah and
then there damond and rise
there's so many of their names I know
lucer jeris all that creativity so
many yeah it's diff I remember it was
one of those things where I read it and
you know when you read something and you
don't hear the pronunciation so you
learn the word in your head by how you
think it sound and I always thought it
was Ria and I remember on the episode
one breakdown I just kept saying riria
and stuff like that and by the end of it
I went back and re-recorded everything
after hearing how it was said in the
episode but I missed a couple
I was say oh this is like 40 minutes
long and I just got I can't keep
recording every single line in it h but
yeah there's um so the weekend ended
with the Godzilla xong trailer Greg I
still don't know how to pronounce the
title of this movie I was talking to one
of our editors and he was like well so
they've started doing this thing in
music where they'll have if there's two
big singers they'll have like Billy ish
X Sam Smith or something and it'll be
like a collaboration and he was saying
well I think it's pronounced and but I
don't actually know because no one ever
says it and I'm looking at it thinking
is it Godzilla times Kong is it Godzilla
X Kong is it
Godzilla an Kong and they did this
didn't make it clear in the trailer I
would you say it I would just say
Godzilla X Kong because that's what it
says there just same way you Brit say
her because there's an H in there I
would say x because there's an X in
there you know what I mean yeah you
don't think the kids are laughing at us
do you thinking look at these old guys
saying is that Godzilla xcong is that
the Godzilla xcong these Elder
kids listening to 90 minute podcasts
like they've got the attention span for
that they were on Tik Tok watching 10c
videos and
just um but yeah what did you think of
the
Godzilla times Kong trailer I mean we're
I'm going to talk about Godzilla minus
one in a little bit uh but I I watch my
my wife is a is a my wife my wife is a
massive fan of gods that's how old we
are Greg you're doing my wife references
refences
all um but the but but uh we
talking Godzilla Godzilla and Kong your
wife my wife my wife she is a huge fan
of the Godzilla franchise like and I
don't mean just the American films she's
seen all the Japanese films she loves
the Godzilla movies and and and then the
night
before um this trailer came out it was
like it was like 11 o'clock it's like
all right you choose what we watch and
she wanted to watch Godzilla versus Kong
again I was like perfect because there's
a trailer coming out and so I'm excited
let's watch this so I can be in the mood
for this trailer so I watched Godzilla
versus Kong the night before so I was
primed for this and
I love the trailer because it just gave
me everything that I wanted like does it
look silly yeah it looks silly it looks
cheesy but it's a it's a slam bam action
trailer and I feel like Adam Wingard is
going to just double down on everything
that actually worked in Godzilla versus
Kong we all know like the Millie Bobby
Brown storyline was freaking boring as
hell in that last movie and I don't see
her anywhere in this trailer I was
surprised to see Brian Tyre she not in
the movie she's not in the movie okay
good not in the film yeah I don't think
we need her character and uh I was
surprised to see Brian Tyreek Henry's
character back because he was part of
that storyline M Bobby Brown and that
was the part of the movie I really
didn't like but doesn't look like he's
going to be utilized that much in this
movie the best part of what Adam Wingard
did with Godzilla versus Kong is
everything with Godzilla everything with
Kong and with the little girl Gia and I
think that's the main aspects of this
that we are going to see more of you
know a lot of times directors get their
feet wet with the first one when you
when you're suddenly like I'm doing this
giant $100 million plus movie with
massive CGI and I don't really know what
I'm doing and I got to figure it out as
I'm going now that he knows what he's
doing and he sees that the parts that
people really connected with were the
elements that were just more Visual and
like like visual storytelling and
expression at storytelling with with the
monsters themselves I think this one
will probably be wackier yet more
emotional with its monsters
simultaneously this looks like real a
lot of fun to me this looks like a lot
of fun yeah that's the main word I've
seen used for it wacky and Greg I tell
you I hate the word wacky ever since it
got used to describe the MCU films like
it's fun and wacky it's just whenever I
hear those phrases fun and wacky I'm
like oh oh no not again um and yeah I
did see some of the criticisms being
like you know if you look at the 2014
Gareth Edwards Godzilla film and then
compare it to this it tonally it's it's
it's pretty different um but yeah I
think it looks fun um I'm not here to
see some introspective massive human
drama in a Godzilla and Kong film I feel
that you know it did work quite well in
the the 2014 film but I think as we've
kind of went through the franchise those
characters have disappeared and we're
kind of left with
like not two-dimensional characters but
they don't feel like big
threedimensional characters either that
and actually some of the the issues that
I've had with Godzilla versus Kong I I
did feel like that that movie was cut
down quite a lot and I knew quite it was
basically rumored to be a much longer
cut of the film that would explain
certain things like um the axe how that
was created some of the stuff in in the
The Hollow Earth that he discovered with
the other apes and when that was missing
from the film I was kind of like H feels
a bit you know like they could have
developed some stuff there but then
seeing this trailer uh it's clear
they're answering those questions and
the issues that I had with that film
because they're going into the scar King
the the other Apes in the hollow Earth
the ones that exist down there and yeah
I think it looks good I mean if you if
you come into Godzilla films and you're
annoyed about them being wacky mate have
got some to show you from the old
days when Godzilla's like skating Along
on his tail and stuff and we've got baby
Godzilla and Son of Godzilla and stuff
like that um yeah this isn't as wacky As
It Gets In the Godzilla world or the
original Godzilla versus Kong movie the
the Japanese one that was wacky
right there yeah that was a lot more
work than this but obviously at the
moment where we've got so much Godzilla
content Greg we've got Monarch we've got
Godzilla minus one which I'm annoyed
about Greg because it's not out in the
UK until the 15th I've managed to get a
screening for the
11th um we were sending emails last
night like count can you just send us a
digital version of the film so I can
watch it please I'm begging but you've
got to see it you out in the states
you've got to watch it yeah how's it
going I've just had a Godzilla weekend
man I saw Godzilla versus Kong for the
third time watch the Godzilla X Kong
trailer and then um I and my wife she
wanted to go watch bringing back to Bora
at me dude she wanted to go watch uh
minus one and I was like yeah you know
what I I wasn't because we do movie reac
actions on the channel and uh John lost
the coin toss uh because he covered Shen
Godzilla which is a great Godzilla film
by the way Shen Godzilla is an amazing
Godzilla film and and so I I want to
take my wife to go see it and we went a
little date night got my big bucket of
popcorn got Center seats on IMAX it was
it was the right perfect viewing and I
heard all this hype about it but I had
I'd never seen the trailer for it I I
didn't know anything about the the film
whatsoever and I don't know what you
know about it I'll I'll avoid some
spoilers here
because it was a
surprisingly
emotional film The the common rhetoric
when you talk about these Godzilla
monster verse movies is the human
characters are boring the human drama is
boring and I'll tell you dude I got
pretty emotional by by the end of the
story it it takes place in the' 40s uh
at right like right at the tail end of
World War II and expands all the way I
think up to like it spans like a couple
of years like it starts off at the end
of World War II into 1947 something like
that and it follows this guy who I
believe his name is kichi and he is
a I guess the terminology be like a
disgraced uh kamakazi pilot like he did
not follow through with being kamakazi
pilot he fled um and he had without
spoiling anything he is this guy
who has an encounter with God and that
is his trauma that is where his PT is a
big part of his PTSD comes from but you
know whoever learns about the fact that
he he was a kamakazi pilot he he's
shamed for not going through with the
actions and so it it takes place in
Japan when they're dealing with all this
loss already postwar it's it's really
like melancholic and
dramatic and now as they're in this
stage of recovery and you're following
ing this guy who who is um has no belief
in himself and doesn't really know what
to to live for and is constantly
questioning why he's
alive now they have this Godzilla
creature to contend with as well and I I
had no idea that it even took place in
like n in in the 1940s so while there's
I believe some references that he could
be you know Godzilla could have formed
from the uh atomic bombs and nuclear
stuff and whatever they don't make
anything explicitly clear in the film
they keep that a little bit more of a
mystery but when Godzilla well I mean
you're talking about World War II in
Japan with a character that's famously
created from atomic bombs you can draw
the connections there you can draw the
connections but it it does because like
when he first introduced it's more of
like a a legendary sea creature that the
people have heard about uh but the way
they have Godzilla move in this movie
dude he
is it's like especially if you're used
to the monster verse where they're like
hey he might destroy every everywhere
everything he walks among but he's our
hero he's our guy we love that Godzilla
we we forgive him for everything he is
terrifying in this film uh there there's
there there's aspect this the way I
would describe my experience with it is
sort of like Dunkirk meets Attack on
Titan I don't know if you've seen attack
ontan but that was the blare I had with
with the way how Godzilla feels here
just this terrifying monstrosity as
you're watching humans who um are low on
resources who who already are in just a
constant state of survival now have to
deal with this
monstrosity yet if they can find a way
to maybe overcome and defeat this thing
that that could give them a sense of
Victory After experiencing such
devastating loss uh post this war and
yeah the Godzilla everything with that
you would expect from Godzilla like the
atomic breath is all there but it's it's
executed in a way with this sound design
and visuals that I haven't quite seen
done with Godzilla like he really feels
it's it's akin to like watching Jurassic
Park for the first time he does have
this like prehistoric dinosaur Vibe
about him with a little bit more hideen
elements because he's Godzilla and could
do some extra but the the weight
the scale there is this talk about how
it's like a $15 million film but it
looks great now I don't really know how
pay works for all these things that are
different for stuff in the US and the
UK there was a point where I was like I
you know I could see how this was made
for $15 million but then there are
certain sequences that happen later in
the film where I'm like I don't know how
this was made for $15 million this looks
way too good it is it is grandiose but
more importantly like Godzilla's
probably only in the film for maybe 20
to 25 minutes out of the whole
experience but his presence cast this
big Paul over the entire film and the
characters themselves you do root for
you are endeared to
and I it's kind of nuts how we're I I
think Monarch is a fine show I like I I
saw the reviews come out for it and
people were like loving the hell out of
it and I I haven't quite fallen in love
with that Monarch show I really haven't
and it's and it's because there's a lot
of characters there and I just don't
really care for a lot of the characters
I really don't but the car but this is
just a two hour film and I I felt so
connected to them and we're like four
hours into Monarch and I am
exponentially more connected to these
guys than I am in anyone Monarch at this
point so yeah like this this is I could
see how this is the standard this could
become the gold standard for what we are
the gold standard think of Tom Cruz
again this is this is the standard for
what a Godzilla movie can be like shin
Godzilla to me is more is more like
there's always going to be a political
aspect uh but that one is much more
politically heavy there's it's snappier
Shen Godzilla it's more fun and they
utilize their practical effects in in
Shin Godzilla whereas here at Godzilla
CGI but that never takes away the fear
element and the way they blend him in
and he's just he really is a menace like
he is a terrifying Menace uh but it's
everything we've ever heard about the
monster verse movies that don't work
that you might forgive would just come
but it's
fun like that's not the case here I like
the the action scenes and stuff are
really cool and and and man are you
engrossed in it uh but it's mainly a
human drama and I think you're really
going to love I I just knocked my mic
away I think you especially are really
going to love it because you have a a
much better understanding when it comes
to you know like World War history and
all that and and while it's it's a piece
of fiction while it's completely
fictional it's still playing on on
things that are very much real so I I
can't wait for you to see it I think
you're really going to love this film
man yeah no I love Japanese well I've
pretty much spent the last four weeks
just watching the ring on repeat um I
love Japanese films and uh yeah yeah I
am really excited to see it really
really can't wait and it sounds like
Greg it's smashing up the box office
which takes us into our next topic um so
it's actually done really really well at
the box office it's breaking a box
office record with1 million on its
domestic debut I believe that makes it
the highest grossing forn film of all
time it's at least the the Japanese um
yeah it's at least Japanese so I might
be wrong on that it's done really well
um so yeah it's done it's doing numbers
it's obviously got a limited release as
well it's not out everywhere um but yeah
Godzilla is back and he's smashing up
the box office and it kind of shows a
transition of where things are going now
that takes us into some negativity Greg
we've got some bad stories about the box
office so you might have seen um last
week that there was a report on Aquaman
um coming from variety which is
basically said that Christmas at the box
office hinges on Aquaman and the Kingdom
being massive movie theater owners are
getting worried their quote says the
holiday season is on the shoulders of
Aquaman and that's not a good shoulder
to put anything on says one analyst and
yeah we do kind of get the feeling that
that movie is going to underperform um
sometimes when we talk about the how
things aren't predicted to do well we
get some comments saying you guys are
making it you're willing it into not
doing well because you're coming out
here and saying it's not going to do
well so people aren't going to see it
unfortunately that is a fair point to be
fair um we do try and basically take
other people's words and and say why you
know they're saying this is it's it's
just kind of parting report um but you
know these analysts and we've seen it
this year as well they are very very
accurate at predicting things they
obviously know um how pre- ticket sales
and they these use things like audience
interests and they are really good at
predicting things you know it's very
rare that they'll say something's going
to be a massive hit and it it's a flop
or you know they say something's going
to flop massively and it's a massive hit
um so yeah it doesn't look good and I I
genuinely feel worried for theater
owners because I think that you know
they limped along with the pandemic they
were often shut um and just knowing that
this kind of hinges on a movie that
possibly isn't going to do very well
well say possibly I doubt it will um it
it it is worrying and I I think this is
just a whole thing with the industry in
general where Behavior has been affected
so much by habits that were given during
the pandemic and the years that followed
it where it's kind of like very quick to
streaming um you know movies have a very
short theatrical run and often if
they're not sold as being events people
just aren't interested in go out to see
them I mean we spent nearly two years
not going to the cinema whereas back in
the past like when I was a teenager if I
was if we were bored on a weekend and we
just were in town we're like oh do you
want to just go see a movie see what's
out whereas now it doesn't really feel
like there's that sort of thing because
you have so many different options at
home you you you can you know you're not
restricted to your VHS collection or
your DVD collection or what's being
shown on TV that night you can just go
on Netflix or something and or the other
streaming services and see whatever you
want to see so it's not so much that
communual thing anymore that it used to
be and on top of that I just I just
don't get it Greg what and this was
something I I criticized a lot of movies
for early in in the year where they'll
release it in the cinema and then
they'll after the opening weekend
they'll announce oh to coming to
streaming in three weeks time it's like
well I'm not going to bother going to
seed at all now and no you know no the
push back I got whenever I brought up
that point was well these movies they've
clearly not doing well out of the box
office the studio behind them is going
to try and make as much money as quickly
as possible by putting it out digitally
and then at least you know they they're
getting some money in the door the
problem is though when people expect a
movie to be mid or even not that good
they're going to now expect it to just
go on streaming straight away so even
like the movies they have are mildly
interested in they're not going to go
and by see it because they know it's
going to come out very very shortly and
uh yeah I think it's just
it's a sign of the times and unless it's
like a massive event like a you know an
avatar or a bob and Heimer or something
like that you you're gonna studios are
going to find it difficult and I think
they're going to need to rain those
budgets in and you know lower
expectations but unfortunately movie
studios H sorry Cinemas can't survive on
that way of thinking and they do kind of
need support from the studios because
the studios for the last couple of years
have actively created a Marketplace that
devalues the cinema and there were times
when they would like you could tell they
were when they were just doing you know
Day One streaming releases on a lot of
films and there was push back from AMC
the studios were being dicks about it
and now it's like you've kind of dug
your own grave because the the behaviors
and things that you've installed with a
shortterm view it's going to affect it
long term because people are just used
to this happening now and they're not
going to Fork out 20 to $30 to go see a
movie that's then either not interested
in or that's going to be on streaming
pretty pretty soon so yeah disappointing
it is disappointing you know I I also
think that they need to figure out a way
to bring
back exclusive you know who does it
Christopher freaking Nolan no Nolan does
it with uh with with his movies all the
time where his Trail the trailers for
his movies will not debut online right
away usually they they are reserved for
the cinema for a while specifically the
iMac screen because whoever's going to
the theaters to watch whatever that
movie is where the trailer's playing
their first experience association with
it is going to be that that trailer on
IMAX where they'll they'll leave that
feeling with whoa I got to I got to see
this movie because look at it here
because it just translates different and
and and I'm bringing this up because
before Godzilla minus one played the and
I watched it on IMAX the Aquaman and the
Lost Kingdom trailer played and and I've
been on this podcast that don't on my
channel too like hey you know the
trailer it just kind of looks like more
of the same it doesn't look that special
to me when I saw the trailer on IMAX I
went I don't know what is it is it
because it's IMAX and I'm seeing the
quality in which this was actually shot
him but this looks like way better this
look this is actually making me want to
watch the movie I I suddenly got hit
with the sense of the visuals look
dazzling uh this feels like a lot of fun
I I want to watch I found myself
actually going I want to watch this
movie I want to watch this movie and
that's because I saw this trailer on
IMAX and I I noticed now when I go to
the
theaters um people are
usually you know showing up like like a
minute before the movie actually starts
because Mo I I don't know what it's like
in the UK but at least out here in the
US there's usually about 15 to 25
minutes of trailers and and a theater
will tell you how many minutes of
trailers there are uh if you if you just
ask them like hey I want to go to the
bathroom I want to buy some food how
much time do I got and and so many
people just kind of Pile in it's reserve
seating so they just sort of wait till
close to a lot of people don't care
about the trailers anymore because they
could already watch it
online and I think that when it comes to
certain films like this espe when you
got something like Aquaman where people
are going Studio the theater chains are
depending on Aquaman doing well you got
to figure out some type of strategy
where if you like premiered this
trailer I don't know it was Oppenheimer
that came out if you premiered this
trailer before Oppenheimer or something
and and it was only playing exclusively
there I think it I don't know how much
of a difference it would have made but I
think there's a reason why Christopher
Nolan does it for his films and I know
some other movies do it but clearly
there's some type of effect where your
IMAX movie goers your your people who
love the IMAX theater when they see that
trailer and especially because these
movies are shot with IMAX cameras a lot
of them are shot and Aquaman and lost
kingdom is one of them so they are they
really hinging their bets on
IMAX if you can reserve your trailers
for then I mean it affects us because
you know we will make our trailer videos
but if we want the movies to succeed I
think that makes the world a difference
because I've seen the trailers for Lost
Kingdom multiple times and it hit me
entirely different seeing it on the iMac
screen it it actually made me want to go
watch the movie and yeah I had that for
the Creator as well I had watched the
trailer online but watching the Creator
I had like a V like an actual reaction
to it I was like tearing up almost just
because the sound the the shots the
emotion that came from it so I do
completely agree with that no way home
was a great example as well I remember
soups was going to the trailer event
that had like they rented out a cinema
just to show the trailer and they were
getting people through the door and that
it's kind of those marketing strategies
that you can use to to get creative and
just build hype for something um and I
think yeah I really do I know we keep
going back to streaming and stuff but I
just think movie studios have just shut
themselves in the foot with what they've
done because they've basic basically
invented
Spotify um but you know they they've
invented Spotify and put everything into
that and you now realize people aren't
buying CDs and that you're using money
and you're trying to get people to go
back to CDs even though the music's
getting released on Spotify now CDs
don't cost hundreds of million dollars
to make um whereas movies do and you've
you've created something that is just
going to has capped your industry um
it's destroyed the physical media Market
that you used to have which brought in
billions as well and yeah it's just kind
of you you've made your bed and and this
is what's going to happen unfortunately
and unless it's a massive event that
people feel they need to go to the
cinema for people just aren't going to
do it and and it's it is going to see
the shutdown of Cinemas and theaters
which is such a shame because there used
to be a hub of you know so places to go
and hang out and before the internet you
guys might not remember but before the
internet you know that was where people
used to go hang out and watch watch
things and you know you didn't know as
much about movies back then you weren't
fully plugged into what the Ron Tomato
score was and that kind of thing you
just went up to the the cinema seeing
what was showing and thought oh that
looks good I'll buy that and go sit sit
for half an hour and decide if it's good
or not and either walk out or enjoy it I
mean look what happen godilla minus one
Godzilla minus one is making more money
than they expected it to and that's a
that's a Japanese movie you know and
Grant it's like Godzilla is a big IP and
all that but still it's at the end of
the day it's it's still an international
movie and to see how it's doing in the
states here and that's because of the
word of mouth like for me to go on like
a a Sunday night I went to like a 9:30
pm. showing um and when I first bought
tickets when I first bought I saw like
oh man the word of mouth on this is
crazy because when I I bought tickets on
uh on Saturday Saturday night and and it
was like oh it's practic empty perfect
and then I show up and most of the
theater's freaking packed all all of the
sudden you know and that's because like
oh the word of mouth is like spreading
like wildfire on this film because I
like 24 hours ago I bought these tickets
and it was vacant and all of a sudden
it's like jam-packed with people so yeah
that that alone I didn't even see the
trailer for it that alone right there is
a testament to making something feel
like an event and and watching the
impact it can have and this is just some
movie that came over from another
country that is doing really well here
you know I think I think it's really
cool and I think that's translated you
know to the Marvels as well which I mean
Disney's pretty much just dumped that at
this point um it's now ending its
theatrical run as the lowest grossing
MCU film in history um and yeah it just
kind of speaks to the state that
Marvel's in at the moment um and you
know that it did feel like they hit the
point of break glass in case of
emergency and the emergency was Tony
Stark um AKA Robert Downey Jr I've never
heard of that guy before I've got no
idea who Iron Man is but
apparently Kevin fari has said they
won't resurrect him well I'm not saying
apparently he has said he said to Vanity
Fair they're not going to resurrect him
and he said we are going to keep that
moment and not touch that moment again
we all worked very hard for many years
to get to that yeah and we would never
want to magically end do it in any way
now nowhere in that quote that they put
forward does he say they're not going to
resurrect him I didn't read the full
article but just that quote saying I
don't see how you get we're not going to
resurrect him from that um I still think
he is going to be in secret Wars
personally um you know I'm not not got
some footage of him on set fighting
against Wolverine or anything but I
personally think he will be back for
that and it's purely just because it's a
celebration of the
MCU um and they do kind of need him back
at the moment as well I mean there is
people who say yeah there is people who
say that he won't be back because he
Demands a massive paycheck and the movie
is going to be very expensive as it is
but I think he will be back and um yeah
I was getting tagged in that so much
with people saying see Robert Downey Jr
is not coming back as Iron Man and I'm
like well we'll say mate Andrew Garfield
was saying he's he wasn't the werewolf
for months and months
um but yeah it just kind of speaks to
the the whole thing going on with marvel
at the moment where it's like you
haven't created as much of an impact as
you need to with these new characters
and um even Deadpool 3 next year I mean
it's based solely on already established
characters that were hit somewhere else
and I do kind of worry about what's
going to happen because ekko's now been
pushed back to
2025 Echo no Echo sorry iron heart has
been pushed back to 25 it feels like
they're just dumping what if over the
holidays and I know every time I'm like
oh what if they shouldn't be releasing
it that like that over Christmas people
are like oh it's only because you have
to work it it's like well that yeah that
is the point but it's not just me who
has to work it Marketing Executives at
who who who does most of the marketing
for for projects sh the studio do a lot
of it but I would say a hell of a lot of
the marketing also gets done for free by
third party sources like your your
YouTubers your ticktockers your Outlets
your actual media Outlets um and if you
don't all those people are taking that
week off H like everyone I've spoke to
even if they cover every single Marvel
show religiously it's kind of
like I'm waiting up whether to do it and
I don't know if I can be bothered to get
give Christmas up but what if happy
Hogan Saved Christmas you know what I
mean yeah so yeah just releasing it like
that I don't think they're going to get
I feel like they're dumping it and um it
is a shame because they would have got
so much
publicity extra publicity from just
releasing it slightly differently to
what they're
doing yeah yeah I mean you got to
convince people that some people just
want
to I I don't give a like like what
what if it's so up and down for me like
I I was surprised by how much better
what if looks from the trailer that came
out out but not having Revisited it I'm
like I am in that position of well you
got to convince people during the
holiday season to to go watch what if if
when they're probably going to be with
their families or doing something that's
more eventful but no stay stay home and
watch it and there's a lot of
competition already for stuff I mean
Invincible did well for both of us on
and that released on on Thanksgiving Day
so perhaps I don't know Christmas is a
completely different holiday as well to
your point too about I was thinking
about the Robert Downey Jr thing they
said the same exact about Hugh Jack
when it came to Wolverine like we're not
GNA touch Logan don't worry it's not
going to be we're not going to undo that
and they're not and and I think Kevin
Fig's really known how
to change up his CEO it yeah he's known
how he knows how to speak I was also the
other part of me is thinking about 2024
they're releasing X-Men
97 and to my
understanding you have to really
know the X-Men cartoon from from the 90s
to to watch this show and they're
putting a lot of work and effort into
this as you would hope they
would and I certainly watched the show
uh when I was a kid yeah I don't
remember I remember the first episode
and I remember apocalypse it's like yeah
I'm like I always remember but I'm like
I don't remember anything else like I
don't I barely remember this show and
they really going to hedge their bets on
uh allowing their Their audience to like
do all this homework to to watch XA 97 I
think that's been a problem with the MCU
is the amount of homework that's
required and and it seems like there's a
lot writing kind of on XO 97 because
they already said they want to do a
season two for it and it's only one out
of three shows that the releasing for
next year for
Marvel and and and I'm like ah I don't
know if X1 97's the
right call right now I mean all of it's
all of The Originals on Disney plus so
you know Steer people towards that but I
mean cartoons if it's just getting
labeled as a Saturday morning cartoon
then I think it's absolutely fine I mean
we we kind of hype up every MCU release
as like oh it's a big event we're going
to be covering it week to week we're
doing it and maybe it's just something
that you put on on Saturday morning for
your kids and you you know like I don't
know what what was that Avengers cartoon
that used to be out Mightiest Heroes
maybe or like a spectacular Spider-Man
sort of thing you know where it's like
it's a cartoon it's it's just for for
kids to watch and consume and maybe
we're just looking at it like this is
the next pillar of the MCU when it's it
might not exactly be that and you know I
feel like it might even be an origin
story for some of the like the The
Professor X from Multiverse of Madness
you don't know um and that might just be
me setting it up where it's not doing
that at all um but yeah it is
interesting Marvel kind of just feel
like they're sort of dumping this stuff
like echo's a a one and done day release
um that's going to be weird to cover
yeah it's weird I kind of hope that they
are analyzing the way that stuff's going
and be like crap we need to just just
you know and it looks like they are
doing this to be fair when you just put
the brakes on pump the brakes and just
take it easy and go back to the Drone
board on a lot of stuff and just come
out with nothing but home runs from now
on because that's what they need because
they're all going up to Secret Wars an
age where the Godzilla universe is doing
the Godzilla IP is doing so much better
than Marvel at the moment so funny yeah
and I mean DC's having their own trouble
as well but on story is that Zack
sniders came out and said that he called
James gun to wish him all the best and
he told him that he wanted it to work
and he added that if gun ever invited
him back to DC he would only be
interested in doing a true adaptation of
The Dark Knight Returns so obviously
Snider took a lot of the elements from
that for Batman v Superman I don't know
if it's too similar to Batman v Superman
to you know what I mean where I mean
it's got the Dark Knight return suit in
it it's got the armor suit it's got
Batman versus Superman in it um I don't
know if it would be too close to that to
draw comparisons but hey if it got
announced that'd be their day one and if
it was like in elor story where they
brought back um both Henry and Ben I'd
be I'd be their day one no no problem I
think the plot is different enough I
think the plot's very different and it's
huge as a m like they had to divide the
animated movie up into into two parts
because of and and the animated movie
didn't even have the the internal
monologue
which is something that Frank Miller is
so known for and they had to excise that
which I which I thought worked in in the
animated film yeah but um I think if you
are going to do a if zacker saying I
would want to do a proper true
adaptation like well you got to have
some of that film War monologuing going
on with with Batman and uh the story
would be different enough and he'd he'd
be
intentionally elderly Bruce Wayne
whereas uh Ben Affleck just played like
older Batman he didn't play like the
elderly version of a Batman so I true I
think he's not like elderly to the
degree of like Batman Beyond where he
has to have a cane and can barely move
but I think it would be different enough
and you get the Joker in there uh the
Two-Face story I think there's a lot of
of the the villains trying to reform and
I think there'd be a really nipples the
mutants the Nazi nipples yeah there's a
lot of really cool things I think you
can do I I love the Dark Knight Returns
I think that's a really great story and
yeah and I think Zack Snider whatever
Camp you fall into with Zack Snyder when
he says he would want to do a onetoone
adaptation you know he would at least go
for it the question is would the soul of
it still be there or would it just
visually match the components of it but
I think with the work that we saw him do
for Zack Snider's Justice League and
then BBS extended edition as well
Watchmen as well I mean he managed to
adapt Watchmen which for many years was
thought unadaptable yeah it's hard he
managed to do that so yeah if he if he
did something along those lines like he
did with Watchmen I think that would
work really really well yeah and rebel
Moon's coming out very soon that was
another reason why I'm kind of like
waiting up do I do what if because Rebel
Moon releases the same day the thing is
if we C like our heavy spoilers is a
small team we don't have like loads of
Ed
we don't have writers it's just me and
Mt doing the scripts in the voice over
and then two editors so if I commit to
doing nine days of what if over
Christmas as well there's going to be
things I'm going to not be able to cover
like Rebel Moon probably Aquaman as well
and any classic movie breakdowns I want
to do so yeah I'm just kind of like uh
do I want to also give that up for what
if when it might not do well and I'd
rather just talk about Die Hard or
something you know what I mean Greg I'd
rather do a Die Hard video coming soon
um but yeah the screen franchise is
always also in trouble too um so this
comes back off the the Thanksgiving
which has been green lit to be getting a
second film um I actually really enjoyed
Thanksgiving I think it's a nice nice
start um and it seems like the scream
franchise is getting rebooted completely
as well Greg so uh yeah spy glass have
came out and said that um it's basically
just going to be the a complete reboot
from start to finish uh after Melissa
Barrera and generala left uh they're
basically wiping the Slate clean killing
the franchise and though Christopher
Landon will remain as a director along
with wrer James Vanderbilt they're
starting aresh so no more Neeve Campbell
um and it turns out that spy glass
actually he he the the head of them Gary
barar is apparently known for for for
being quite cheap and we saw that with
um NE Campbell in regards to how she
asked for her her salary and apparently
Barrera was actually fired a month
earlier and Barber's apparent takeaway
was that you know he got rid of Neeve he
can get rid of Melissa as well and he
kind of just saw as being like look we
can make Scream movies without them
personally I feel like they've shut
themselves in the foot I think um it's
going to be then the reboots going to
get a lot of negative publicity around
it and I think they need to give it a
couple of years off before starting
again but they're going full steam ahead
with it and just saying now just start
scream again who cares so yeah it's a
bit of a weird one and I kind of hope
that Thanksgiving takes over its place
and just kind I mean it's got Patrick
Demsey in it so it can do it um so yeah
just you guys
[Music]
suck so all in all you guys suck yeah
yeah
SC the screen franchise is real really
buming me out it's my favorite horror
movie franchise and to see what's become
of it lately has been so disheartening
it really is a dejecting
experience because I this is the first
time we're living through a time with
the scream franchise where the
conversation around like like I know
Scream 3 wasn't well well received it
wasn't but this is different it's it's a
different kind of drama as opposed to
having a bad installment of in a movie
or a not liked installment in a movie
this is something entirely different um
because now
you're you're you're truly messing with
story and you're messing with people's
lives and you're messing with characters
it's really there's just a really shitty
everything all around behind the scenes
and and and then also how it affects the
story as well it all it's all just a big
shitty thing and it's a lot of like out
it's a lot of drama of surrounding the
film
franchise that is not the actual story
of the movie itself it's everything
surrounding it and that is becoming the
entire conversation and and it's
important to shine a light on all those
things it isn't it is important but it
completely
cast a negative Shadow around an
otherwise pretty great franchise you
know like I'm not it just I I don't know
what the hell you would do with the next
Kareem movie and it just makes it seem
like a really messy
experience already because now we're
already living in a they haven't even
started filming it right and we're
already living in in in a in a world of
going what what is the alternate reality
of Melissa Barrera wasn't fired and
general Ortega was returning and we got
that complete Trilogy with those
characters that they did set up now
we're already in that reality of the the
what if scenario of that you know yeah
and then that's and it might get to the
point like 15 years where they just
think oh we'll bring them back and do
like the final SC I mean they did it
with Halloween yeah Jamie the amount of
different times it was like jam Lee
Curtis has left and then she's come back
to do Halloween yeah against Michael
Myers and they did that so many times um
they probably going to do it again they
did The Impossible with Scream Six they
really did of like neev C like they had
Carney Cox come back uh but they didn't
have neev Campbell and neev Campbell's
been the she's the face of scream you
know she's the Lori stro of scream in in
in some ways more than Lorie stro
because they were able to continue many
she the Nev cbell of Scream the Nev
Campbell of scream because she's
and while in Scream five I thought they
kind of just shoehorned her in there
like she wasn't really necessary for
scream five they still decided to move
forward with Scream 6 and do and they
not only got rid of Nev Campbell they
also placed it in New York City they
took a very different approach uh with
this franchise and it ended up becoming
a really huge success and was very well
received by fans as well so they did
something quite special and and this is
without Wes Craven as well you know
that's that's the other thing like
without Wes
Craven and and to see the what what's
become of it I know I'm just kind of
like stumbling over my words here it's
just a really disart to me it's it's one
of those weird situations where I I care
more about this than I do the Marvel's
failing and not being a well Reed movie
like I I care way more about this and uh
yeah sounds like you need to wake up
great
and that takes us into our sponsors
today we got a sponsor guys it's G you
might have seen Greg drinking that you
wanna you want to take it away dude I'll
take it away man I'll take it away
because you guys might see have so many
leftover cans of G fuel just spread
around the office you might have seen me
drinking G fuel cans many times here on
the podcast U my life mainly consists of
every day in the past few months I'll
work out meditate film for like an hour
or two and then just a whole bunch of
com variety of computer work and often
having like 10 to 12 hour days messaging
Paul late at night and a lot everything
I do requires a good amount of focus and
staying sharp and having a lot of energy
and also with getting
healthy I the the diet that I went on
was uh having a no sugar added
diet and gfuel
I love the drink I had always wanted to
work with them because I started using
their product before I ever worked with
them I specifically sought them out
because I'm like I'm already using their
stuff let me just see if I if if we can
work with them because I already use
their stuff every single day and I I
found that it has drastically helped me
with my energy my focus we shoot these
at a time where I
normally I'm usually like quite foggy
minded as a matter of fact this morning
um Paul was messaging me and then I
totally fell asleep again because I was
just so like uh I was a little
overworked I was like I need to I need
to pick me up so I made myself a g Fuel
and like now I can talk about Godzilla
minus one people let's go so yeah I I
love I really do believe in in this
product I really do I I love I love G
what flavors do you recommend Greg go
that's a great question um let's see
over there I got I'm just going to grab
like the my assortment of cans there's a
nice pack right there hold on hold on
here's a good like a bunch of leftover
cans of just me just drinking that I
just haven't thrown
out um I got a hype sauce which is a
great one uh everyone who comes on the
channel they love the orange Vibe so I'm
out of that one now as the leftovers can
and uh this
I don't even I I'm one of those people
who I'm like what's on the cover I want
to drink that like oh Naruto I love
Naruto I'm G to drink that this Dragon
Ball Z1 the strawberry Le I don't even
know how to pronounce that yeah they're
all good I think all of them are great
my wife is also quite addicted to them
as well my wife my wife so yeah and yeah
well thanks chue for sponsoring us um
we'll drop a link to that in the comment
if you want to pick some up and yeah get
energized guys love get it get it get it
now speaking of people who aren't
energized at the moment right I feel
like Bob AER needs some bloody G fuel
because he's had a Disney shareholders
call and the guy has just done he's
sounding like us on the podcast just
been talking about he's been talking
about all the stuff that Disney's doing
wrong at the moment and I feel like oh
you being too I'm writing in the
comments you've been too negative guys
you've been too negative Bob but
basically he's come out and said the
main point that he said was was um they
their main goal now is quality over
quantity which asking a corporation to
do that oh I don't know mate because the
way this that corporations work in
general is you put something out it's
successful and it's then how can we make
more of these and it's not necessarily
always like oh you're overworking us and
we're not really making a good product
yeah they're like don't care get it out
get it out keep pushing it out so
apparently they're going back to quality
over quantity which you know more will
have stri back there releases we're
getting Deadpool 3 next year and no none
other films um and but he did talk about
this back in 2020 they had a similar
sort of situation with the shareholders
where they basically said the same thing
and but there were some other things
that he talked about and he said that
creators at Disney have lost sight of
what their job should be which is to
entertain first not messages he added
that stories infused with positive
messages for the world can be great but
it shouldn't be the primary job and I'm
sat here thinking Greg bloody hell like
do you know which the two most popular
films of the the a are like bobie and
Oppenheimer which are both filled with
politics messages messages like yeah
lots of messages I'm talking feminism
I'm talking nuclear disarmament and
that's just Barbie so oppenheimer's
obviously filled with it as well in all
those Senate hearings I kind of feel
like this is sort of him pandering and
trying to be like sounds like someone
watched the RSE special and pan yeah
yeah and like let's be honest mate you
can make good films with positive
messages in them there's plent like top
gun Maverick is a really great film and
it's got great positive message about
attacking unknown enemies and destroying
all their resources and weapons um but
obviously there's lots of you know
positive messages and films and it
doesn't necessarily you should have it
as part of the the story and I think
what Disney's main problem has been is
that they've made mid movies that also
like just feel like almost box ticking
exercises and you look we're not saying
anyone should be that that inclusivity
should be taken away I think everyone
should feel like that they can at least
relate to something on on a certain
level but they kind of have hit a point
where their storytelling has suffered
because of it but I do kind of feel like
the wrong message is going to be taken
from this and that Bob Iger basically
means like well we're making every
single person a white man again and that
was the reason movies were good in the
first place and it's like no mate you
you can still tell like diverse and
interesting stories just just work on
the actual writing for the stories
themselves prey is another great example
I'll keep bringing prey up watched it
again the other day because I got the 4K
features you know a kamanche um woman I
believe I'm pronouncing that right it's
very it's lace with like how how she's
going against her tribe which are like
you should stay at home and look after
the tribe and she's like no but I want
to go hunt but it it's such a well done
story that that doesn't matter and yeah
just you can tell it just doesn't see
things from a sort of Storytelling point
of view he just sees things as well we
were making money when we were doing
this and now we're doing this and we're
not making money anymore it must be
because we're doing positive things it's
like May every single Disney movie for
like the
100 years has a positive message in it
what the hell are you talking about yeah
yeah I
think I think from understanding like
screenwriting to a certain
extent usually a message will come
through um just from telling a good
story and from telling a good character
I watch Godzilla minus one now without
giving any spoilers away other than like
okay yeah we were aware of like war and
all that uh if you just just look at the
character Arc of the of the main
guy he's he's a very coward cowardly is
not the right word but he he's someone
who just he couldn't follow through with
what he was assigned to follow through
with because he didn't have something to
he didn't really believe in it the cause
and a big part of that character is him
learning to um find Something to Believe
In and and and so right there is a
message guarden of the Galaxy 3 is is
like one of Disney's Only Hits this year
and exactly and and like you know
there's there's tough stuff in there
about like Rocket Raccoon and he's it's
his movie and it's a beautiful story and
then if you like break it down uh so
much of what that movie
explores um uh the animal cruelty side
and the the experimentation on animals
that we do in in society as much as
people are are like hey there's no
political message I'm like I don't know
about that guys there's definitely some
messaging in this movie when it comes to
like animal treatment and animal cruelty
and all that you know and and a lot of
times messages just sort of come through
when you're telling a character art and
I think the problem that happens is is
not that oh we have to entertain first
not messages it's it's that when
you sometimes a movie can get bogged
down with like what is the message on
our whiteboard that we have to
communicate first and then let's design
stuff around that uh versus kind of I
noticed the the the powerful effect that
really connects with audiences is
usually the reversal of that I think
that's why Barbie still works really
well because while it can get quite
hamfisted and very on the
nose it still is so rooted in the
character's Journey
that as as um as much as like there's
like a fourth wall breaking element to
it it it's still so rooted in the
characters you know and sometimes I
think these movies they do get they do
think about the message first or
whatever like uh instance I would say
the problem that often happens with
Disney is that sometimes their messaging
in
inclusivity just registers is a little
insincere even though it's like yeah
that's an important thing that's a good
thing but it feels like
the yeah I think the paner special
exists because you can tell that the way
they do it sometimes just feels
insincere and that's why I wanted to
cite Guardians of the Galaxy 3 because
it's a character-driven spectacle
film but you can still take away quote
unquote messages from it that are very
positive messages for the world yeah you
know well we've seen this recently with
the Marvels which basically for me just
summed up Disney's idea of
representation which was that Valkyrie
and cap in Marvel had a scene where it
was hinted at that they used to be in a
relationship together yeah but they just
cut it out and it's kind of like well if
you can just cut it out because it's not
really part of the character it feels
like you just threw it in to be like oh
well we can have a line that'll panda a
gay people and get them to support the
movie because again what it boils down
to is these corporations want you to
feel like identify with them with
something that you feel passionate about
so you know gay people have been true so
much throughout history where they've
been there's been violence against them
they've had their rights taken away you
know I mean Alan cheran's a great
example of all the stuff he did in the
war and then yeah like what happened
with him was a complete tragedy yeah and
there's actual like struggles for stuff
but when they're just so so obviously
gay people they they feel they see
themselves represented in something
they're going to support it because it's
like oh all these years have being like
like this it it feels like we have
someone to Rally behind and and H bomber
guy has actually done a brilliant video
talking about a YouTuber called James
summerson who kind of talked about all
the the um gay voices that have been
silenced throughout the A and kind of
looked over but what the twist was was
that he was basically plagiarizing all
these things and taking it's an amazing
video go check it out um the plagiarism
in YouTube PL is that what it is
plagiarism in yeah yeah yeah go check it
out it's like three hours long but it's
it's an Incredible video you won't
regret it um so back to my original
point was that obviously you know people
feel passionate about it but the reason
the corporation's doing it is to get you
to associate your own identity with this
brand so that you support it because
it's something you you're you're
passionate about and you believe in and
and thus when it's like oh well we we
did make them gay but we can just cut
the line out that's not genuine that's
not sincere that's not actual character
development you haven't written the Char
Char to be like that you haven't given
the that a proper you know if he can
just remove it completely from it then
it's not really part of the character
and it sounds like you were just
inserting it to do it and that's what I
feel a lot of Disney's representation is
it's it's purely just can we put a line
in there that'll make us look inclusive
and whatever but really if we need to if
we change our minds just cut it the
out yeah um and it kind of boils sound
to that and Bob Iger actually during
meeting talked about how the Marvels
failed because it was it was shot during
the pandemic when there was a lack of
Executives on set I'm like mate the this
movie wouldn't have been saved with more
Executives what it needed was actual
like maybe the executives to step back
because I feel with a lot of Disney
movies at the moment it's almost like
they've got their hands in everything
it's kind of like we cut this down we
need to make it two hours like there was
a mandate with the MCU clearly and they
they've never admitted to this but there
was clearly a mandate where it was like
the movies need to be two hours they
just need to be two hours long and we
saw so many films suffer because of it
that might even be and this might be
sacrilegious there might even be a good
cut of th love and thunder out there but
it needed to be longer and yeah it just
kind of feels like Bob the the Marvels
didn't fail because there there weren't
enough Executives on set being like uh
can we uh do this and do that no there's
two kinds of producers too you know like
there's the producers with the the
people and every producer is kind of a
money person but there's also the you
know like a creative producer sometimes
you see like I think JJ Abrams is a
fantastic producer oftentimes I think
he's a better producer than he is an
actual filmmaker because he's known to
be to get really involved and and
spilberg too when spilberg does decide
to get involved sometimes spilberg just
produces a movie it's like yeah my
studio did it but but when he's like
actually hands on with in terms of
giving Crea input or asking the right
questions a lot of times the creative
producer is akin to the way how uh you
hear about you know musicians who hire a
certain producer to be with them in the
recording booth so that way they can
help guide their album or their song to
be the best it could be by asking the
right question Bill Spectre yeah so and
and I think you need I think those are
the kind of producers you need more
involved in your in in in your in your
movies especially your big 10 Poole
films like this are are the ones who can
go in there and and be like you know
what's actually kind of off about this
like they kind of work as a bit of a
reviewer or they they pose certain
questions they help guide and and I
think JJ Abrams is is a fantastic
producer uh and he that's why I think a
lot of his movies have done really well
uh the Bad Robot ones because even even
like he did Mission Impossible three
which I love I love that one but he
continued to produce the franchise uh
after that you know and I think he was a
big part in getting um totally forgot
his name but the guy who did mission
impossible for Ghost Protocol Brad
something or another um but BR Brad Bird
yeah yeah
yeah so my point with that is that
getting more Executives to be like you
know maybe like because you want your
director to have the the ability to
create and and and so I think that when
we hear Bob Iger say these things we all
kind of know what he's referring to it
just sounds more like he's referring to
more of those like management people
when really what I think they need
is when we talk about Kevin feige being
spread too thin this is part of the
problem here whereas it seems like
before when there wasn't a gazillion
projects that Kevin feige was forced to
kind of be involved in
he could be that producer that I am
talking about that producer who can be
there to get involved with the story and
help guide like when those leaks came
out for Amazing Spider-Man 2 uh on Sony
and and the Kevin feige's notes that he
gave that completely got
disregarded that's the kind of producer
I'm talking about you know where I don't
know if any of you guys remember that
but he gave all these suggestions of
what would have made this a better movie
or a a more focused
film that is all story based it's not
anything to do with
finances and when we say feige spread
too thin it's like well yeah I mean if
you have less projects the producer that
you're looking for who could help make
the Marvels or Thor love and thunder
those kind of movies probably stronger
films the answer could still be in Kevin
feige he just can't be working on like
50,000 projects of once he's got to be
able to be like involved in the one
project that's being made at that time
uh yeah and I think just in general with
Disney I feel like a lot of their movies
are very cookie cutter like I can look
at a film and be like this is a Disney
film because it's just so inoffensive
it's trying not to like Snow White's a
perfect example just being like we're
not doing this and we're not doing this
and the old way it was done was bad it's
like I like I get you guys are scared to
do anything that might offend anyone but
you know we're live in a time where
where someone's getting offended by
something stupid and it it just feels
like they're so tone back and almost
like scared to do anything and it just
makes for
very mediocre by the Numbers movies that
don't have their own voice don't really
have any staying power don't affect you
on an emotional level because there's
nothing in them that really is going to
yeah connect with you and it's just all
kind of yep it's another Disney movie of
just churning out the same thing again
now Bob Iger has come out said since
then that moving forward there they'll
only green light sequels if the story is
strong enough to stand up as as its own
fil and you know something like light
yeah for example where it's like should
you be doing this but this is the guy
who's obviously green lit Toy Story 5
and Frozen three and Frozen four and
stuff I think this is a lot of crap I
think they're just going to keep green
light and sequels and just m because
Disney don't come up with new IPS ever
they just have what they have and they
just try and just milk it as much as
possible um and yeah I can't see that
happening I cannot see them just being
like will only greenl good sequels
because there's such a process you have
to go through to make a movie and no one
green light a movie thinking it's going
to be bad you don't green light and go
this is going to be let's
let's give it a hundred million dollars
um you obviously think every film's
going to be good and the amount of
scripts that Studios get that get turned
down because they don't think they're
going to be good yeah so I think that's
a lot of crap I think if frozen the next
Frozen movie does amazing at the box
office they'll obviously be like yep
just green like the next one get another
one out there I don't I don't know I
don't know what bober saying honestly
like I really don't because he he's
saying the most basic like
everything he's saying is the most
Baseline like well yeah this is the got
it from mus I know like this is the most
statements one can make and and I'm
going are you trying to say that while
you were gone this is what was happening
and and and now you're going to course
correct it bringing it back to this I'm
like but I I feel like you guys were
also still doing this kind of doing this
when you were around before CH came over
you know uh so I don't really I feel
like he this is s of that
pandering because it's it's the most
basic like we're going to make
quality over quantity uh we're not going
to make a movie unless we know it's
going to be a good movie you know like
nothing he's saying is anything that is
like
whoa this Disney's really gonna turn
around now you know like the mo the most
I think he's saying that has been that
has changed is him acknowledging that
maybe we kind of shot the gun like like
blew our load a too much when it came to
uh how much Marvel and Star Wars we were
doing and we need to dial that back that
is the best like it's an obvious
statement but that is the best thing he
could have said like yeah okay we
realize we're doing too much of that we
need to we need to reduce that but
everything else he's saying is just so
so simple and so obvious that it's like
this is what everyone always says about
anything it's not it's not it's nothing
mind-blowing and yet it just sounds also
like uh
weirdly and it doesn't ever sound
hopeful or encouraging in some ways it
just sounds insulting in in a strange
way when you break it down that it it
sounds like he's throwing shade at
something and uh yeah I don't it sounds
like he's a hater sounds Disney
ha ha he's like what culture ruining
stop we need to stop making sequel guys
he's basically walked into the the
shareholder call like like someone's
someone's on their bed thinking what
would I do if I was the head of Disney
right now I think I'd stop making
sequels I think I'd go quality over
quantity I think I'd probably stopped
pushing so many messages in all my films
and then psychically they've sent that
message to Bob Iger who's just before
the shareholder call he's received the
message and he's just listen it up and
it's like yeah well this stuff is H I
don't know as a movie studio executive I
think a lot of it is just kind of saying
whatever to to please the shareholders
what we know though Greg is that this
isn't going to be an overnight thing
that changes there's a lot of movies
already in the pipeline have been saying
for for years now I've been saying look
Disney are going to have to eat a lot of
sandwiches before they can actually
turn the ship around because the so many
things so many of these things are
already in production like when we knew
the Marvels you know Echo uh
there was so many F like things that I'd
heard behind the scenes were going to be
bad and it was kind of like well look
Marvel just need to get through these
and they're going to be good and it was
the same with DC when they had all the
movies when going to taken over and it
was like we've still got to release
these movies we just got to get through
it and it does yeah it will it will take
a while to see these effects now you
might get some cases where they clearly
edit lines out of things to avoid
offending certain people or Turning Away
certain audiences I think that the issue
is they just got too far into politics
and just kind of annoyed too many people
and it it's going to take a while and I
personally think it will take Chek
leaving and it'll kind of be like when
like our Corner Shop um had such a bad
reputation and then I was jogging past
it the other night and it had Under New
Management as a big sign and it it's
kind of like look guys Bob I get gone
we're we're underne management and
everything's fine now come back to us
come back to us and yeah I think they'll
take that kind of thing like remember
when um David zaslav took over Warner
Brothers everyone was like oh yeah New
Management David zlab it's all going to
be great now yeah and even when Bob Iger
came back there was a lot of positivity
like Bob aiger could have happily
retired as being one of the greatest
CEOs of all time and I truly believe
that and if he hadn't come back we'd
probably be sat here right now going
this never would have happened under
Boby girl but we live in that reality
where bober did come back and it has
happened on a bober yeah so yeah speak
it's just crazy and speaking of David's
zaslav our final story for the night
guys and W let you get away is that
David zaslav says scrapping films for
tax write offs took courage and then he
said with to The Verge what content is
going to help us win the content that
wasn't we made a strategic decision on
it was difficult and painful but it was
necessary I'm just thinking that sitting
like David there's no bravery in just
dragging a a film folder over the
recycle bin and dropping it in that
you're deleting thousands of people's
work and you know you don't know how
that movie would have gone or been
received by the public
and I do feel like they should have
released backl personally I mean it
might have damaged the brand but like in
hindsight mate DC's brand is
anyway Dam to the point where you've got
Aquaman made a billion dollars paid over
a billion dollarss and it's now looking
like it might destroy Cinemas worldwide
because it's not a good movie to to lean
on and it's like that I don't see how
much more bgirl would have damaged the
brand and obviously you know it would
have it would have been a good thing for
for women to watch and you know see a a
version of Batman in themselves or
obviously she's not a version you know
what I'm saying like someone like a
Batman sort of hero but it's a woman and
uh yeah just
just crazy to come out and be so bold
that it's like it took courage takes
courage to delete films so I can make
like tax get a tax rate off of millions
of dollars for the corporation I work
for and most of us guys when when we
worked for corporations and stuff back
in the day anything I could do to
the company over I'd be like I'm
doing that I'm just doing that is the is
the
uh well first off if he actually thought
the movie was bad the courage would be
in releasing the movie and going
maybe like this film um but is is him
say I'm trying to understand why he used
the word courage is is the is the idea
that he used the word courage because he
would get a lot of hate for it well like
that's that's what's happened is he he
was like shunned a lot for for doing
that and I'm the new guy now I'm canning
this movie and I'm aware people are
going to get really mad at me I I have
no idea I think that's what he means was
going to be a show yeah he thought
it was going to be really bad and get
everyone to hate him and he was like oh
I mean that has happen yeah but I mean
I'm sure the hundreds of millions of
dollars and you know billionaires boy
club that he goes to every year I'm sure
that keeps him you know takes his mind
off stuff no one appreciates the courage
it took for
yeah just such a ton deaf thing to say
like you're a idiot man like
genuinely hire better PR people please
to come out and be
like I I'm really sorry what just say
I'm really sorry what happened with
Batgirl unfortunately you know we were
weighing up what op this is how I would
handle it say look I'm I apologize to
all the creatives behind Batgirl
unfortunately we were in a tough
position financially where it might have
affected the company in a me in a really
negative way and unfortunately we might
have to lay some stuff off we didn't
want to do that and the only other
option was making the tough decision of
unfortunately having to let B girl go we
obviously have a new universe coming out
as well that we felt it might contradict
with that and we're just tired of
letting the fans down with promises the
things that we didn't think were going
to materialize in the end so we're
really sorry it happened we wish the
creatives behind it all the best and and
we hope that people still rock with us
huge thank you but instead he's coming
out like me I mean it was difficult
wasn't it what I had to do deleting that
movie to to make a tax right off a
million deleting all those people's hard
work that they've worked on for years
and years because that's how long films
take to
make was tough but uh yeah guys managed
to do it it's kind of like on Mission
Impossible when Ethan Hunt climbs the
skyscraper and uh he gets knocked back
in the window and then Benji rushes back
in it's like
well it was tough but I managed to get
it done and he's just been doing like
the easiest job ever so yeah well done
SZ lab I think I feel like every week we
kind of have a a back and forth about
who's the most hated CEO that week and
I'm guessing that because obviously and
we now know from the talking points that
all the CEOs listen to this podcast I'm
guessing that every week the people from
Universal put it on and like thank God
thank God I'm not getting mentioned it
was like when I was watching the H
bomber Guy video and I'm like I'm I'm
got mention in this one I'm safe for
another year so uh the like I think we
try to you know as much people say like
this podcast brings out I mean I think
it does brings a little bit more of like
some of the things that we find a little
bit more negative in the indry but I
think we at the same time we still try
to have like a a conversation about it
instead of just like screaming the same
talking points you know what I mean and
I'm not saying like some of those other
channels they actually some of some
there are some other channels that
definitely do that and there are some
that um definitely get more nuanced
about their approach and I think we try
to have a bit of our nuanced approach
but there there is a certain camp out
there that I do feel like Bob Iger has
been perhaps seeing a lot more of thing
going you know what we have we have
divided I think I think there's one
Disney has done is they really have
divided Their audience significantly and
I don't know what's going going on with
do like I really love the last episode
of Doctor Who but is there do you know
if there's something there about because
I've been hearing as I thought I thought
Disney just got the rights to put Doctor
Who Up on Disney oh I've got no idea no
idea I've watched them both um I like
the last episode yeah I've got no idea
what the got no idea what the whole
situation is contract wise with them
yeah I mean it kind of feels similar to
to the older stuff to me personally
obviously they've got Disney stepping in
and doing some stuff but I don't know
how what the extent of that is or if
it's just just distribution I'm guessing
it's just distribution you don't know to
be honest the BBC is pretty much just
Disney over here
so I don't think it would have changed
that much anyway I think even if Disney
hadn't been involved probably be getting
the exact same shows because there is
that conversation I keep seeing about
like Disney's affecting Doctor Who and
I'm like are they I thought they just I
thought they just they can just air it I
didn't know that like are they
creatively they getting involved yeah I
mean they might be they might I mean it
is going out on their streaming service
worldwide so they might have some input
and be like look you can't do this you
can't say Disney are corporate ghouls
that will suck the souls out of
everything that they own and you
definitely can't say that about the show
you're on right now guys yeah I've got
no idea um but we've just had a report
come in an exclusive from variety saying
that a Spider-Man Noir liveaction series
is in the work as Amazon has brought on
Steve light but as co- Sher that'd be
quite good um Spider-Man live action
I've actually been rereading the
spiderverse comics at the moment edge of
the spiderverse and uh yeah it's good
who was in that quite a lot who can't
wait to see that who's Steve
who Steve light foot I've got no idea
who he is mate yeah we'll quickly skim
the report um not it's not like foots
first foray into the Marvel world he pre
previously developed and served as the
showrunner on The Punisher Netflix
series let's go
baby this is going to be so that's a
great pick for Spider-Man what oh we did
oh he worked on
Hannibal
oh like super dark damn yeah this
is good man I mean Spider-Man are gonna
be like super dark the hell I guess my
only Rand Association is the
into the spiderverse you know but I I
don't know like the source material of
uh Spider-Man new o but yeah excited for
that nice positive note to end it on the
CEOs are probably crying right now but
uh sorry guys I'm sure the money will
keep you warm at night and you know you
just get a hit out there and we'll be
back um but yeah thanks guys for sitting
through this with a thumbs up we keep
forgetting to ask people to Thumbs Up
And subscribe the videos so if you do
that you'll get a lovely little
thoughtful prayer from me where I
instilling you the knowledge to take on
in your own shareholder phone call um so
yeah if you want to support us please
hit the Thumbs Up Button um thank you
again to our sponsors CH fuel you want
to listen to us on the go um and you're
not using YouTube you not you don't have
YouTube premium basically we're on
Amazon podcasts Spotify Apple podcasts
yeah thanks again for joining me Greg
hopefully we'll be back next week with
some more news baby woohoo so yeah I've
just realize next week uh when we're
recording is when I've got tickets for
shin H for Godzilla minus one so might
have to rearrange something but we'll
get back to you guys and thanks for all
your love and support hello